il mondo di youtube ormai è cambiata
ormai la gente è diventata
incontentabile c'è troppa concorrenza al
giorno per chi non basta più un horror
dove ti spaventi facilmente a farti
arrivare a 20 milioni di visualizzazioni
per chi in tendenze ci finiscono sempre
video per bambini di tre anni
dovrei forse fare un video di risposta
alle cazzate che spara su di me e ciccio
gamer per fare più facili oppure potrei
piangere davanti alla videocamera come
ha fatto lui
youtube è la mia vita non posso mollare
tutto così perché così difficile portare
qualcosa che genera interesse se magari
fossi veramente io sbagliare come posso
io da solo risolvere il grande enigma
dell'intrattenimento come posso io
valere qualcosa in un mondo di numeri e
di social forse non troverò mai una
risposta a tutto questo potrebbe durare
in eterno questa situazione
lo si city sto ascoltando rimini prima
però mi stai su fondo blu
no è perché ti spiego youtube è un po
caccia dei problemi insomma non è una
cosa vecchia come abbiano no non è
vecchio perché comunque body soul
algoritmo non funziona poi va bene non
so più cosa inventarmi per fare gli
iscritti poi la qualità aumenta e non so
manco più che cosa devo fare sul mio
canale perché sei pieno di cose si ha un
altro pro qualità se non sicure su
youtube line 20 calza sta leggendo però
non so come fare levi usa non so il mio
canale ward so più cosa fare te lo giuro
io faccio tutto e metodi o come logan
paul trovi un morto della foresta o come
lo camp onlus viticoltura box e chi
sfido a porsi scusami ok clinico che i
nostri veramente no party cene a portare
ok non te li ricordi mi serve
no dai c'è da votare
si vogliono incontro pulito va bene in
croce di contorno
[Musica]